I don't understand being a night person
we love the nighttime and watching you
know two movies in a row sometimes I was
anxious to see Marty
sc's movies again you know I was just
blown away by them Good Fellows and I
wrote him a note because it was like how
you know we you made us laugh at at
Killers so you wrote him a note after
you saw Good Fellas again and said hey
you did such a great job I bet he really
appreciated that because
he answered me and I was talking about a
movie that I was once asked to be and
directed by him and I said I'm so sorry
I didn't take that role but I didn't
think was a good it was called Alice
doesn't live here anymore you turned
down Splash you turned down Alice
doesn't live here anymore there was a
lot of uh mentions of movies you turned
down you could have had any movie
because there's a part of me that's very
lazy I don't believe that for a second
you don't it but you're such a worker
work when I work and I'm a total worker
you know totally concentrated on that
project but then when the projects
finish I am so happy to be not
working now I mean I just love to be
around family and my grandchildren I
haven't had time for friends in 10 years
cuz I wased totally dedicated to this
book except when I had to earn some
money everyone I'm sure assumes you have
like a billion dollars at this point
sure I wish but I see why you wouldn't I
wish to have it to give it away when you
would make movie deals you had 10% of
the money for what's up doc the movie
what's up doc how stupid yes you
participate in the profits you go to a
early screening people aren't laughing
at the film you say to yourself this
movie is going to tank I better get my
money up front you gave away 10% of the
gross it went to 15% after break even it
was worse than that Howard I actually
gave it up because my business manager
said you you need the cash you have no
money you know and so I sold out for $2
million and I remember Peter bogdanovich
saying what are you crazy him and Ryan
kept their percentage and they probably
made they made a fortune I didn't I had
to go and sing you know to to do
that